the second part of the trip we it got a
little bit nature so you already kind of
paranoid a little bit I wake up that
morning and go to the bathroom I get the
camera now I'm filming huge gecko black
and it's just on the wall like a burglar
like Spiderman he probably looking at
the camer like the black dude
looking at me you know me and look I
don't have an issue with it outside my
room come inside my room that's when
it's like it's like who makes these
rooms why would you not put no type of
glass something you got sound like
racist white people you stay outside the
house like I got no problem with black
things what you come inside my house
surpris I understand racism I spoke my
name with a K when I saw
that I had a hood on when he showed it I
like cam what are you doing with this
pillow on your hand what's going on yeah
you must be lost he said get that liger
out of
here get that lier